joining us now for reaction here in
Washington with me is Kellyanne Conway
counselor to President Trump and the
first female campaign manager to manage
her way in to victory for a presidential
candidate that no one thought could win
happy Anniversary Kelly Ann what's going
through your mind I want to talk about
Virginia in a moment but I was just
thinking about being at that Hilton
Hotel a year ago and watching the big
screens I was on Fox early in the night
and I really wanted to be at the Hilton
because I wanted to be with the people
who supported the President and seeing
those screens up there and then they
meet her going up up up up up likelihood
of President Trump to win take us back
into the room where the president was
that night it was historic and euphoric
as you know and he came to the 14th
floor of the Trump Tower where our war
room was set up and we had a data
analytics war room set up on the fifth
floor but he came and then his family
started filing in one by one to watch
the returns the most guarded and least
self-congratulatory person that entire
night was Donald Trump he had been a
dealmaker his whole life and he knows
the deal is not done until the final
paperwork is signed and so but what we
saw happening was we saw that the New
York Times for example their upshot was
changing I think they started out the
day with like a 10 or 15 percent 4
percent 7 percent chance or something
like Michigan which he did win and then
it started to creep up and up and up and
then we started to get our own data and
we knew which counties were left anyway
I just want history to show that it was
Donald Trump that connected with people
and he was able to take issues that were
really very arcane to lots of folks like
trade and immigration and convert them
into top-shelf issues that he's still
fighting for now he has a 70 point
immigration plan as president he's
renegotiating these imbalance unfair
trade deals so that they work more for
the American worker but he flipped
counties that President Obama had
carried twice he flipped states that
President Obama had carried twice and
those who still will not accept the
election results those who neither
expected him to want to win or wanted
him to win
I feel they've wasted a whole year and
not getting to know why he won the same
reason he won is no expiration date just
a year later he won because he was able
to make people feel that someone was
giving voice and visibility to their
everyday concerns that forgotten man a
forgotten woman the people living
paycheck-to-paycheck the people who say
the system's always rated against me
they have a nose pressed up against the
glass looking in and look it's not like
people yesterday in New Jersey and
Virginia across the country said we're
now gonna be a movement of hats saying
make America mediocre again that's not
happening people still want their taxes
cut they want the border secure they
want prosperity they're happy these
regulations are rolled back and I would
say that even those Republicans who
always seem to be critical in the
naysayers imagined who would be sitting
in the old Gore cities they were really
they were willing to risk that Kellyanne
though they build Bristol bill kristol
that whole never Trump crowd some of
them have turned around but way too many
are still sitting there going oh my gosh
if only if only Evan McMullen
if only Evan McMullen could could
possibly do public in one that you see
I'm neutrality Joe Joe Biden said this
earlier today he called it this phony
nationalism the reason why the world is
compared to America is not just because
of our exercise of our power but it's
the power of our example it's because of
who the hell we are his the message from
him is we're not who were supposed to be
under dominance he's very bold now that
it's revealed that Donna Brazile and
others thought about swapping Hillary
out and him in but the fact is even Joe
Biden didn't have the courage to run for
the third term of Obama Biden because he
knows that based on his own definition
that people looked up and saw a economy
that wasn't even a 2% growth we had for
decades Laura before 2007 an economy
that consistently had 3% or better you
got to put some points on the board more
than more than just uh fat you guys have
done dreg Keystone that at the beginning
of NAFTA renegotiation and of course
this tax reform they're trying to push
through those are big things but we
still need happy voters i they were
happy under Reagan voters were happy in
the first few years of Bush I just
didn't like Bush that much sometimes but
they were happier it's a lot of anger
out there and that Trump in that victory
speech I'm the president of all
Americans are we gonna see him travel
the country those pockets that don't
support Trump we're gonna see that
yes and he has gone to places that
haven't necessarily supported him but I
want to say Lara that he put that in the
speech up in the residence the speech
the two versions of his speech had been
sort of prepared but he put that in
there those were his words and he had
lived after that even those who didn't
support me there were a few of you and I
have often hearkened back to that very
passage in in his speech in his words
because he means it and people are going
to benefit from tax cut student in
support and when I travel around this
country and we're doing either drug
demand or healthcare I don't ask the
people in the room who they voted for
when I went to a manufacturing plant
recently Roanoke Virginia
I didn't say please raise your hand if
you voted for Donald Trump review it I
don't much care I want them all to
benefit from it but you're right about
the optimism that's the peace and the
happiness that hasn't quit yet I mean
there's consumer confidence um is up but
the the optimism about these
conservative populist policies working
keep our nerve happy voters years to get
Obamacare repealed and replaced because
they rely that they can keep their
doctor in the plan and there are 20 some
million Americans who still don't have
health care but this president he was
called today the most pro-life president
in modern in modern American history too
and I think people really don't don't
fully appreciate what that means this
person who gave the most impassioned
defense of life on a debate stage I've
ever heard his number so against Hillary
Clinton so I think that's actually
become look I'm so old I wrote a piece
eighteen years ago called The Unbearable
Lightness of approval rating so I talk
about it when they're up over there down
I think that's become a quiz question
and people are angry about any number of
things so it's easy to see I disapprove
of the system it's why the media the
mainstream media's numbers are much
lower than his gunner courses of 20 to
pursue his numbers in muscle Oh what
about Galecki though Kelly on Kellyanne
you've known him for years the only guy
who campaigned with him well did
fundraising for him is George W Bush
Georgia B Bush tried to you know pull
Jeb over the finish line in South
Carolina that didn't work what does that
tell you about Bush ISM and the old
establishment party Wow look he's he
worked for the bushes and what I think
it does say though is that candidates
matter campaigns matter and we've all
known a glossary for a long time he's a
great person he would have served with
great integrity as the governor of the
Commonwealth I think voters have to
figure out what what running in the age
of Trump means it
means that you want to articulate lower
taxes fewer regulations border security
which means the wall and other
mechanisms so that we stop all the drugs
and the illegal aliens from coming over
the border but it also means it means
optimistic prosperity and I think it
means not being baited down every single
rabbit hole to know what you do but I
think Edie there's also a New Jersey guy
who is a lobbyist I mean how you drain
the swamp is all obviously yes exactly
know what I would say I mean I I think
that I'm you know as a good guy we need
public servants like that who want to
run at the same time in 2009 so
President Obama is elected in 2008 2009
rolls around Christy McDonald in
Virginia yeah and you know one month
later what happened Scott Brown a
Republican I helped if I help them with
that she did but this is what happens
sometimes and I do think that there are
dynamics at play in 2018 that go against
the party empower Republicans but
they'll have a fundraising advantage
yeah and people are not seeing much from
the Democrats the women their message is
that what it was a year ago but your
message a year ago is the message today
but Trump's bad and we're not Trump not
a message right it's it's a resistance
of anything it's resistance the the
numbers and again this is Virginia which
is essentially a blue state in many in
many ways because in Northern Virginia
women minorities those blocks went big
for Democrats made for Democrats Oh plus
65 white males forty to fifty five forty
to sixty four went for Gillespie gotta
broaden out that reach of the
conservative popular fella it's true and
it's the message that matters because
for example Donald Trump lost among
women by about 12 points 12 or 13 points
to Hillary Clinton d woman the queen bee
but not by 20 no and he had this message
where he was consistent and he was
convincing and they saw strong
leadership where he was giving voice to
working men and working women the job
holders not just the job creators and
not just the job seekers but the job
holders the vast majority of American
households and he had a message of
patriotism too he says look I'm going to
go around the world and deal with other
leaders is on his fourth or fifth trip
right now doing just that lar but at the
same time he makes no apology that
America is a sovereign nation that needs
borders and
own decisions and that his first and
foremost goal is to keep us safe and
prosperous here and he expects other
countries to think the same on the
Muellers on the mother investigation
that's one thing he couldn't have
predicted I'm sure he knew it was gonna
be a rough sled with the media as mad as
they were that they were exposed on
election night they were embarrassed and
exposed so most of them are still out
and but they're still but it's like
nothing's change it's like Thompson even
win no no but they're clinging to that
same narrative today but nevertheless
you know I think Donald Trump didn't
expect Muller he didn't expect the
investigation mania he didn't expect any
of that how distracting is that to him
on a day-to-day basis you're with him
you see him it reports art he's obsessed
with the investigation he's obsessed
with Jeff Sessions appointing a special
counselor or stepping aside recusing
himself I should say is he the only
thing is obsessed with his succeeding
for the nation and I see that firsthand
every single day he rarely talks about
the investigation and he has also said
everybody will comply with it but we
hope it finishes fully and soon
Kellyanne great to have you with us very
happy anniversary Congrats again a year
ago I want Trump elevated women he told
us